let's go to the phone lines and see
what's on people's minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 I have a caller from country code
86 I have no idea where that is
country code 86 where are you calling
from
yo I actually made it on no I'm cool
drop o to you recently not like for them
I'm comments like on yourself
I'm calling from China you sorry yeah
we're treating yes sir
ok the show in China is that easy to do
yes sir um don't tell anybody this but I
have a VPN and I watch you on a regular
basis now what do you do in China I
teach I teach ceramics and I teach
social studies okay
to what what age goods oh oh
also please forgive me I curse yeah I
like to make a blog within a sec oh
pardon me partly I try my best to
abstain but I teach grade middle school
in grade 8 in 12 fascinating and use do
you speak the local language yeah I get
around I'm not really really flowing but
I get paid to speak English so uh you
know ASAC yeah it's not really a frowned
upon but they try to make us speak as
much things as possible because students
gone rambling part me okay well listen
uh hear from your first caller we've had
from China what's on your mind that's
what's up um okay so while I was reading
I was thinking about a poignant question
asking the man one thing is how do you
feel American politicians nowadays would
all just talk about morale Muller or
just talk about the dams the Republicans
how they hate each other and all the
other nonsense
yeah why aren't we talking more about
the water pollution that is happening
all through the southern states and the
Midwest
and how more and more reports are coming
in of children being poisoned by this
water how communities are being poisoned
by this water in how
it was this fact being being known Flint
isn't even being spoken right about in
the news media nowadays and is still a
problem children are still being
reported with record highs of iron in
the blood right and irony so sir iron or
LED you're talking about
my bad I said iron my bed I apologize
I'm a little bit there's a couple
different things going on okay so there
let me uh we'll go from like highest
level to lowest level high level from
the media perspective we know that one
death is a tragedy and a million is a
statistic or whatever the phrase is so
when 10,000 kids die in Africa from
hunger today and 10,000 died tomorrow
it's the same story it doesn't have a
defined beginning middle and end it's
not appealing for corporate media so
that's number one and that relates to
the media coverage of the water problems
we have in the United States but here's
the other thing that's really important
to consider um we have right now we have
a president who doesn't care about that
okay we have a president who yeah if
he's even aware of these problems is a
pollution and climate change skeptic has
no I mean listen look at what happened
with Puerto Rico and his hurricane
response so I agree with you that we
have a problem that corporate media is
not talking about issues of pollution
and water enough completely agree with
you I also think though that we need to
remove the guy in the Oval Office and
put someone in who cares a little bit
more if we actually want government at
the top level to do stuff about it but
the other important thing is a lot of
these issues are dealt with at the state
level water is a state issue in many
cases water can be polluted by companies
that are federally regulated but it's
also a state issue so a lot of it has to
take place within the states yes yes and
with that being said I would love to see
more covers on your show no or bringing
more people in from Europe and from
areas who were being affected by
fracking in areas in Louisiana and
in areas of Mississippi and Alabama even
like just like you know scouring for
people who you know we need their voice
to be heard and people here you know
here you listen we're looking I believe
and we're working on two interviews
right now related to knots not so hyper
specifically water but that are in the
ballpark and I'm gonna make every effort
to talk about it more you know thank you
so much and I really do appreciate you
taking my call it is 114 a.m. in China I
need to take my mm I need to go to bed
so I may be fresh and early I may be our
fresh air before the bestows it all
right there really appreciate all hope
to hear from you again we will put them
in the phone system as a good caller
we'll put them in the phone system as a
good caller